hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well early on in
Chapter six of his language truth and
logic a jair is going to provide us with
a breakdown of what he takes to be going
on in some sort of systematic account of
ethics so when we think about moral
theories for example or the works in
which they are articulated whether these
be presentations or books or articles
you know or as he says the ordinary
system of ethics as elaborated in the
works of ethical philosophers he's going
to tell us that this consists of a
number of different types of things or
classes of components or statements if
you like and he tells us these are not
homogeneous that means that they have a
number of different functions or they
have different natures to themselves and
before we look at the four that he picks
out as being ethical in some sense it's
also worth noting that he tells us that
very often systems of ethics contain
pieces of metaphysics analyses of non
ethical concepts if we want to think
about things like a platonic dialogue it
might also include
you know all sorts of character
development and setting all of that we
want to push aside and say okay what's
the actual ethical content of some sort
of expression some sort of systematic
articulation of how it is that we human
beings ought to behave what's good and
bad what's right and wrong and how we
should understand all of these manners
so air will tell us that there's really
four main things going on and we could
distinguish them from each other we
could pull them apart and you know think
about taking a book for example like his
own and maybe we have four different
colors of highlighter and every time we
see something going on with you know the
first class we highlighted as light blue
and then yellow and green and finally
maybe pink for the other class or we
could do so in in many other ways as
well maybe we could even like break the
text down and say let's take all of
class one and put it over here all of
class three and put it over here and
thereby develop new texts so what are
these he tells us that the we may divide
them into four main classes there are
first of all propositions which Express
definitions of ethical terms or
judgments about the legitimacy or
possibility of certain definitions
sounds rather abstract but that's
actually you know the part that air is
most interested in as it's going to turn
out Lee says then secondly there are
propositions describing the phenomena of
moral experience and their causes so
we'll come back to that in just a moment
because you might be wondering well what
are phenomena of moral experience let
alone their causes third he says there
are exhortation to moral virtue and what
does an exhortation and expectation is
saying that somebody ought to do
something you're trying to convince them
or trying to stir them up to do
something so when I tell a student for
example you know
was anxious about the exam I said just
do your best right
I'm exhorting them you're probably not
gonna get everything right but just try
your hardest I'm trying to produce some
sort of action on their part albeit in
this case an action that's at a second
level you know an action about their own
actions use your Faculty of will to make
yourself do things this way or look on
the bright side or anything like that
now an exhortation of moral virtue would
be saying you should do something that
we take as being good or don't do
something that we take as being bad and
then finally he says we also have actual
ethical judgments so let's come back to
the first class again propositions which
Express definitions of ethical terms or
judgments about the legitimacy or
possibility of certain definitions so
you know we not only have definitions we
don't just throw them out there we say
is this a good definition does this
actually work can we define something
like this we can go on further and have
as he says comments on definitions may
be we require some explanation for that
and interestingly enough he tells us
that this first part so he says it's
easy to see that only the first of our
four the our four classes namely that
which comprises the propositions
relating to the definitions of ethical
terms can be said to constitute ethical
philosophy so the only thing that really
should strictly speaking count as ethics
itself in terms of ethical philosophy
would be this first class what about the
second class interestingly air is going
to push that off to what at that time
were the premier social sciences now we
have many many other social sciences and
a lot of overlap between those things
and here he's talking about he calls it
propositions describing phenomena of
moral experience so
nomina are the things that appear to us
the things that we have deserve right
and moral experience would be that
entire realm of things that we either we
directly observed or somebody else
observed or could observe that have to
do with some sort of value so when we
say for example World War two resulted
in horrible loss of life but it was
quite important to fight totalitarianism
even if we also had to cooperate with
another totalitarian regime that is the
Soviet Russians we are we are engaging
not just in some sort of you know
definition process but we're describing
moral phenomenon we could say you know
what is it like to actually have to kill
another human being is that a bad thing
is that a good thing
does this thinking about it in terms of
doing your duty or saving civilians or
preventing a much worse outcome or just
being brave does that help you in any
way these are things that we would call
moral phenomena and air thinks that
philosophy really can't be concerned
with this so this means that a lot of
things that we find in older ethics air
would say that's not really ethics
that's for the scientists to determine
and which scientists in his case he
talks about the psychologists and the
sociologists psychologists focusing on
the individual or the individual and a
small context sociologists focusing on
groups we might include economists we
might to some degree include historians
we could include studies of
communication anthropology all sorts of
other things but the point is here air
thinks that any of this stuff in class
two really doesn't belong in philosophy
not even in that branch of philosophy
that we call ethics going on to the the
third part exhortation to moral virtue
err points out that these aren't really
prappas
at all they might express themselves in
in the form of pseudo form of
propositions like it is highly desirable
that you complete your work on time and
diligently write if I write something
like that I'm really not just saying I'm
telling you what happens to be highly
desirable it's up to you what you want
to do no I'm telling you I want you to
complete your work on time and
diligently do that because I think
that's good I'm going to give you a you
know rah rah if you do that and I'm
gonna give you a boo if you do otherwise
right these are not propositions at all
as we've said and expectations could be
to all sorts of things you know if the
word moral virtue is tripping you up
just think about exportations commands
injunctions attempts to convince people
of something maybe even salesmanship
might fall in there you really can't
deprive yourself of this new
refrigerator that's probably an
exhortation right it is using some what
ethical language you you know you've got
to exercise your right to be a good
consumer it's something along those
lines that's really in that third part
then we have actual ethical judgments
and at that point in the work when he's
going through these these four types he
says as for the expressions of ethical
judgments we have not yet determined how
they should be classified but in as much
as they are certainly neither
definitions and or comments on
definition so they're not the first part
nor quotations we may say decisively
they do not belong to ethical philosophy
so insofar as they're not involving some
sort of definition they're not really
part of ethics a little bit later error
is going to set out an analysis of
ethical judgments where he'll say they
they often have some factual components
those we could actually like you know
reasonably disagree about and have
decision procedures for figuring out
but they also have ethical components to
them ethical terminology and that is
really just an expression of our
emotions or it's an attempt to get other
people to feel the same way that we do
or to induce some sort of action on
their part that leads into the emotive
theory of ethics that he develops there
so coming back to this air is making
this distinction why in part because he
says that unfortunately the distinction
between these four classes plain as it
is is commonly ignored by ethical
philosophers with the results it's often
very difficult to tell from their works
what it is they are seeking to discover
or approve heir says that if we're not
distinguishing between these four
classes of propositions we're going to
get ourselves all muddled up about what
we're doing in ethics and he thinks that
most other philosophers do in fact do
that so he wants to restrict ethics per
se to this this first class he's gonna
stray out of that in his own work he's
not entirely consistent with that but he
is giving you an interesting taxonomy if
you like of the different classes of
ethical contents or if you like you can
say propositions understanding or
statements understanding that that some
of these are actually pseudo statements
or pseudo propositions they are not true
or false but merely express moral
sentiment feeling preference or try to
get other people to feel the same or to
do things so that is the classification
that he provides
you